[Musique]
il n'y a pas de bataille de budget il y
a un débat sur le budget
il n'y a pas une bataille rangée entre
groupes parlementaires
il y a un échange de conviction pour
tracer la meilleure voie possible pour
les finances publiques de la France
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro
grandeur l'année parlementaire le budget
vous le savez le gouvernement ne dispose
que d'une majorité relative et les
oppositions c'est une constante vote
toujours contre le budget dès le début
l'équation est compliquée pour le
gouvernement et la menace du 49-3 plane
dans toutes les têtes
le retour de l'inflation
déstabilise profondément notre économie
elle déstabilise profondément les
économies de tous nos partenaires
européens
elle déstabilise profondément l'ordre
économique mondial
dans ce contexte
un budget est un choix un choix
politique qui va être discuté je
l'espère longuement intensément et
sereinement pendant cette semaine
notre priorité c'est de protéger nos
compatriotes
protéger nos compatriotes contre une
inflation qui sème le trouble
l'inquiétude protéger nos compatriotes
qui sont confrontés non seulement à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie mais
désormais à la flambée des prix
alimentaires
protéger nos compatriotes les plus
modestes qui sont confrontés à cette
impôt
inéluctable que représente la flambée
des prix de l'énergie comme de
l'alimentation en octobre 2021
avec cette majorité
j'estime que nous avons pris une des
décisions les plus importantes du
précédent quinquennat en mettant en
place un bouclier tarifaire sur les prix
de l'électricité et sur les prix du gaz
les premiers en Europe nous avons décidé
de geler les prix du gaz et de plafonner
les prix de l'électricité
en 2023
nous maintiendrons ce bouclier tarifaire
au nom de la protection qu'avec Gabriel
Attal nous voulons apporter à nos
compatriotes il coûtera 46 milliards
d'euros dont une large partie sera
financée par le prélèvement des rentes
sur les producteurs énergétiques au
total en 2021 2022 2023 nous aurons
dépensé 100 milliards d'euros pour
protéger nos compatriotes contre la
flambée des prix et contre le retour de
l'inflation
notre deuxième priorité après la
protection de nos compatriotes
c'est la protection de notre industrie
et je veux le dire sans détour
notre industrie est directement menacé
par la flambée des prix de l'énergie
je tiens à redire à quel point il est
essentiel de poursuivre notre politique
de l'offre et la baisse des impôts de
production engagée depuis 5 ans
avec Gabriel Attal nous proposons donc
dans ce budget de supprimer la CVAE en
deux fois en 2023 et 2024 pourquoi la
CVAE parce qu'elle bénéficie en priorité
au PME industriel et qu'on ne peut pas
dire d'un côté qu'on veut rouvrir des
usines rien du scaliser le pays
reconquérir l'industrie française et de
l'autre continuent à accepter des
niveaux d'impôts 5 à 6 fois plus élevés
que nos partenaires européens vous avez
la force de la cohérence mesdames et
messieurs les députés de la majorité et
vous avez la force des résultats car
vous êtes la seule majorité depuis 20
ans qui a recréé des emplois industriels
dans nos pays et qui a ouvert plus
d'usine qu'elle en a fermé soyez-en fier
et tenez bon sur votre ligne de
politique économique
[Applaudissements]
ce budget de 1023 doit permettre
d'atteindre les objectifs que j'ai
rappelé en début d'intervention engager
la baisse de la dette publique à partir
de 2026 revenir sous les 3% de déficits
publics en 2027 je constate que les
oppositions ont adopté en commission
tout groupe confondu plus de 7 milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires
je connais des manières plus efficaces
de rétablir nos finances publiques la
nôtre en tout cas sera claire tenir les
dépenses à plus 0,6 en volume sur la
durée du quinquennat c'est l'objectif le
plus ambitieux qui était fixé en matière
de finances publiques et de dépenses
depuis deux décennies ces responsables
c'est raisonnable et comme je viens de
le démontrer c'est parfaitement
compatible avec la protection de nos
compatriotes et de nos industries face à
laflation
oui ce budget est un budget de service
public jamais notre pays n'a autant
investi pour l'éducation nationale 3
milliards 700 millions d'euros en plus
dès l'an prochain pour revaloriser nos
enseignants recruter des milliers
d'accompagnants pour enfants en
situation de handicap jamais notre pays
n'a autant investi dans la sécurité et
dans la justice un milliard 400 millions
d'euros en plus pour recruter 3000
policiers gendarmes supplémentaires dès
l'an prochain 8% d'augmentation pour le
budget de la justice pour recruter et
mieux rémunérer des milliers de
magistrats et de greffiers dans notre
pays 3 milliards d'euros en plus en
soutien à nos forces armées dans un
contexte où la guerre est revenue au
coeur de l'Europe et nous devons
poursuivre le réarmement de notre armée
jamais notre pays n'a autant investi
pour l'écologie et pour faire vraiment
la transition 1 milliard 500 millions
d'euros pour soutenir les projets verts
des collectivités locales 250 millions
d'euros pour le vélo
100 millions d'euros en plus pour ma
prime rénov oui nous sommes au
rendez-vous de nos responsabilités pour
faire vraiment la transition écologique
dans notre pays
protéger les Français face à la crise
renforcer nos services publics maîtriser
notre destin rien de tout cela ne serait
possible si nous laissions ce budget
être rejeté par reflexe par symbole ou
par habitude
mesdames et messieurs les députés j'ai
pleinement conscience du poids des
habitudes les lois financières tout
comme les lois de programmation des
finances publiques n'ont jamais été des
objets de consensus la majorité a
toujours voté pour les oppositions
votées contre c'est cela le poids des
habitudes symboliques mais en juin
dernier les Français nous ont
précisément demandé de changer nos
habitudes ils nous ont demandé de nous
parler d'inventer de nouvelles méthodes
c'est ce que nous avons fait ces
dernières semaines avec les dialogues de
Bercy
c'est ce que nous avons fait ces
dernières semaines en rassemblant des
parlementaires de tous les bancs de la
majorité de l'opposition de l'ensemble
des groupes de cette hémicycle pour
travailler ensemble au service de nos
concitoyens puisque vous persistez à
vouloir ramener le déficit public à
moins de 3 % d'ici 2027 tout en
continuant les cadeaux fiscaux plus
riches c'est donc mathématiques vos
objectifs ne seront tenables compris
d'une compression sans précédent de la
dépense publique en quelques mots c'est
une catastrophe qui se profile encore
moins de services publics alors qu'on
n'a jamais eu on en a jamais eu autant
besoin encore moins de justice sociale
et fiscale alors qu'on en a jamais eu
autant besoin encore moins de réponses à
la crise écologique alors qu'on en a
jamais eu autant besoin encore plus de
misère plus de crises dans les hôpitaux
les écoles les files d'attente à la
pompe et à l'aide alimentaire tout cela
simplement au nom de préceptes
économiques défectueux nous avons besoin
de mettre de l'argent sur la table pour
tenir le coup mettre de l'argent sur la
table cela doit se faire au service des
citoyens au service du climat au service
de la biodiversité encore plus quand
nous traversons une crise sans précédent
ou tant de gens ont peine à se déplacer
se loger se nourrir dignement on
pourrait espérer que dans ce genre de
situation exceptionnelle on met à
contribution les surprofits de ceux qui
non seulement ne participent pas mais
même pour profiter de cette situation je
vous demande solennellement
au gouvernement de ne pas mettre en
place le 49,3 par rapport à des
prérogatives essentiels de l'Assemblée
nationale
le débat doit avoir lieu j'espère que
tous les blocs de tous les groupes
d'autoris d'opposition feront bloc
contre ce passage en force entendait
qu'une motion de rejet n'est pas la fin
du débat vous n'allez pas vous dissoudre
nous allons simplement ré-avoir un débat
sur des bases plus saines où
l'opposition sera entendue et où la
motion de rejet est aussi la capacité
pour un groupe politique ou pour les
groupes d'opposition de dire une chose
simple un gouvernement qui ne veut pas
les écouter non nous ne voulons pas de
votre projet de loi de finance comme
dans la manière actuelle
vous dites augmenter le budget de l'État
dans les ministères mais quasiment
toutes vos mesures sont en dessous de
l'inflation en dessous de l'inflation
c'est une baisse et ça veut dire que le
démembrement de l'État va continuer dans
ce pays à des hauteurs que nous
n'imaginer même pas
s'agissant des recettes de l'État nous
observons plusieurs choses intéressantes
que les classes populaires et ce qu'on
appelle les classes moyennes en gros
l'immense majorité des Français
contribuent de plus en plus au budget de
l'État parce que dans les 300 milliards
et quelques de recettes mais on constate
que dans les recettes sont issues aussi
la TVA la taxe sur le pétrole sur
l'essence
ces taxes ont augmenté et les recettes
de cet axe ont augmenté considérablement
puisque les prix ont augmenté
pendant ce temps nous savons aussi que
les fortunes les plus riches du pays
elles contribue de moins en moins à la
solidarité nationale avec des cadeaux
comme la fin de l'impôt sur la fortune
ou de la flat tax des mesures purement
dogmatiques
inefficaces qui nous rappelle tous les
jours qu'Emmanuel Macron et le président
des riches
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 339
exprimé 336 majorité 169 pour 80 contre
256 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
la motion de rejet préalable
protéger les Français et aller vers le
plein emploi voilà le sous-titre de
votre projet de loi de finances or à sa
lecture nous pouvons que constater un
abîme entre vos promesses et vos actes
bien loin de la Renaissance quinquennat
s'ouvre dans une atmosphère de fin de
règne votre budget ne montre qu'une
seule chose vous subissez et surtout
vous faites subir aux Français vous
subissez l'inflation qui vient avant
tout de votre soumission à un modèle
économique mondialiste qui a aggravé les
dépendances de la France la preuve le
déficit commercial qui chaque mois va de
record en record vous subissez
énergétique démarrer dès septembre 2021
que vous faites payer aux Français par
leurs factures par leur impôts par la
dette vous subissez le chômage de masse
vos opérations de communication ne
masquant pas les 5,4 millions d'inscrits
à Pôle emploi c'est juste 400000 de
moins qu'en 2017 vous subissez la dette
cherchant sans doute à battre le record
de 600 milliards supplémentaires en 5
ans à ce titre Monsieur le Maire
respectez les Français ne leur faites
pas l'insulte de parler d'un budget à
l'euro près quand votre déficit est de
150 milliards le gouvernement se
désintéresse totalement du
rétablissement de nos finances publiques
cela n'a jamais été une priorité de la
précédente majorité mais c'est désormais
la dernière de ces priorités alors que
nos comptes sont dans le rouge et que ce
rouge devient écarlate la France
s'affiche à un taux de dépenses record
mais les dépenses courantes vont encore
augmenter de 62 milliards d'euros et
vous allez recruter
fonctionnaires supplémentaires la France
est dans le quinté des pays les plus
endettés d'Europe avec une dette qui va
dépasser les 3000 milliards d'euros mais
notre déficit se creuse encore à 155
milliards d'euros un tiers de nos
dépenses sont désormais financées par la
dette et donc les générations futures la
charge de la dette tutoie les 60
milliards d'euros et va devenir le
premier budget de l'État après
l'éducation nationale et au moment même
où les taux d'intérêt remontent à 2,5%
et même un peu plus la France va
emprunter 270 milliards sur les marchés
un record absolu pour compléter ce
tableau édifiant la France affiche un
déficit commercial record de 150
milliards d'euros alors que la récession
menace enfin la France reste le pays
d'Europe après le Danemark où les taxes
et les impôts sont les plus élevés
d'Europe
vous retenez pour 2023 une prévision de
croissance de 1% que tous les instituts
et le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques lui-même juge irréaliste et
vous vous réfugiez derrière ces
hypothèses avantageuses pour sauver tant
bien que mal la face le problème c'est
que même avec vos prévisions atteenables
la France décroche et nous sommes
relégués parmi les pires élèves d'Europe
ceux dont les comptes sont dans la
situation la plus critique ceux qui sont
à la merci de leur créancier et
pourraient demain être attaqués tout
change et rien ne change sur le fond
après cinq années difficiles marqués par
un conflit social majeur comme la France
en avait pas connu depuis longtemps la
crise des gilets jaunes une crise
sanitaire mondiale une crise économique
profonde une inflation record qui
étrangle et français et le retour de la
guerre en Europe nous discutons du
premier budget du second quinquennat du
président Macron ces orientations et ses
priorités demeurent sinistrement
identiques à celle des cinq dernières
années après une baisse d'impôts de près
de milliards d'euros sur le premier
quinquennat et après avoir supprimé la
redevance télé dès cet été nous
supprimerons la CVA conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République parce que le niveau de nos
impôts de production est le plus élevé
d'Europe il pénalise notre industrie et
la désavantage par rapport à ses
concurrents il nous faut donc agir sur
ces impôts de production mais n'oublions
pas non plus que le sujet premier pour
nos entreprises reste celui du coût du
travail il nous faudra également y
apporter une réponse dans les prochaines
années
aucune des propositions que nous avons
pu faire aucune des préoccupations des
Français que nous avons fait remonter
n'a été réellement pris en compte ni
l'urgence d'investir pour que les
Français puissent isoler rapidement leur
logement ni la situation tendue des
collectivités locales qui sont obligées
aujourd'hui de fermer des équipements de
proximité des gymnases des piscines ni
la situation de ramatite de l'hôpital
public et il aura fallu mener ardemment
le combat sur les super profits et sur
les jet privé pour qu'enfin vous preniez
quelques mesures insuffisantes en ce
sens et pourtant nous sommes force de
proposition les écologistes sont déposés
162 amendements pour faire évoluer cette
première partie du projet de loi de
finance mais là vous semblez jusque là
restez fermé à toute évolution l'arme du
49-3 que vous annoncez ne fera que
souligner votre échec ce suit de celui
de dialogue de Bercy où la sympathie la
disputer à l'inutile dans une formidable
mise en scène digne de falconeri dans le
départ et de sa célèbre maxime tout
change pour que rien ne change en effet
votre boussole reste sans aucune forme
d'autocritique ces fameux traités de
Lisbonne et de Maastricht qui font des
règles libérales le Nord à ne jamais
perdre quelle erreur les récentes
élections dans des pays voisins
devraient pourtant conduire à interroger
vos certitudes car voilà où nous
conduisent les folies libérales c'est
une ineptie de poursuivre dans cette
voie alors que les super patrimoines
explosent 1000 milliards d'euros en
richesse cumulées pour les 500 plus
grandes fortunes c'est une première
c'est un record dans notre pays pourtant
vous ne prévoyez nullement une nouvelle
redistribution des richesses un partage
de la valeur ajoutée tiré du travail de
toutes et tous plus favorable aux
salariés au service public et moins à la
rémunération du capital et elle
accumulation pour une petite caste de
privilégiés
en 30 ans 10% de plus de richesses
produites soit près de 250 milliards
d'euros ont été accaparés pour rémunérer
le capital et une étude de la Banque de
France de juin 2022 montre que cela n'a
pas servi l'investissement productif à
contrario les chiffres des dividendes
versés par les entreprises du CAC 40
n'ont jamais été aussi florissant 57
milliards l'an passé auquel il faut
ajouter 23 milliards de rachats d'action
avec comme symboles total et c'est 2
milliards 600 millions d'euros versés à
des actionnaires au mépris des salariés
et de nos concitoyens seignaient à la
pompe à essence vous réduisez des impôts
à crédit sans diminuer le taux global
des prélèvements obligatoires au lieu de
réduire les déficits publics en priorité
globalement le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire approvisionnel 2023 et de
44,7% du PIB mais ces tests son niveau
en 2018 où est la réduction
en fait vous avez fait qu'une moindre
hausse des prélèvements obligatoires
mais pas de baisse est-il sérieux de
supprimer en deux ans la CVE au coût
brut de 8 milliards d'achever la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
2,8 milliards en 2023 de supprimer la
redevance de visuelle pour 3 milliards
alors que les déficits publics en 2023
sont maintenus en apparence à 5%. vous
augmentez les dépenses publiques d'une
façon excessive car comme la soulignait
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques
votre affichage d'une baisse en volume
de 1,5% des dépenses publiques est une
présentation fallacieuse qui dissimule
en fait une augmentation de 0,7% si l'on
utilise le déflecteur de prix du PIB qui
est bien plus représentatif que l'indice
des prix à la consommation et si l'on
élimine le coûte des mesures liées à la
crise énergétique ce taux d'ailleurs est
peu différent 0,7% de la croissance du
BIP en volume qui est de 1% d'après vos
prévisions et qui risque de se dégrader
nos débats dans cette hémicycle doivent
permettre d'avancer sur tous les sujets
nous sommes tous ici investis la
responsabilité de légiférer cela
implique de débattre en conscience des
propositions de réforme qui
permettraient d'améliorer le quotidien
de nos concitoyens je pense que la
stratégie de blocage que certains sur
ces bancs pourraient chercher à avoir en
bloquerait et créer une forme
d'embolisation du débat parlementaire et
nous obligerait à avoir recours au 49-3
n'est pas la bonne méthode en ce qui
nous concerne quel que soit l'issue de
nos débats nous y prendrons pas avec
l'ouverture d'esprit et le sens de
dialogue qui caractérise notre couple
dans un soutien résolu et constructif au
gouvernement et nous assumerons jusqu'au
bout notre rôle de parlementaire
démocrate membre de la majorité je vous
remercie
les députés commencent les discussions
par l'article liminaire normalement une
simple formalité puisqu'ils seuls de les
comptes des années précédentes et donne
les prévisions pour l'année 2023
pourtant son examen va s'avérer beaucoup
plus compliqué que prévu
nous voterons évidemment contre cet
article pour une raison simple on peut
pas fonder une politique pour la nation
fondée sur des mensonges et des
illusions les illusions vous les
connaissez ce sont vos projections
macroéconomiques elles ne sont pas
fondées elles sont critiquées partout
tes institutions à tant soit peu
sérieuse elles sont critiquées par les
députés du rassemble national qui ne
croient pas à cette hypothèse et les
mensonges c'est les objectifs que vous
fixez et c'est les politiques que vous
prétendez suivre et moi j'avais une
question en fait pour attaquer un autre
position je vais vous la donner tout de
suite sur l'article linéaire évidemment
votre acompte mais j'avais une question
tout à fait solennelle à adresser à
Monsieur les ministres est-ce que le
débat que nous commençons aujourd'hui va
servir à quelque chose ce matin le
Conseil des Ministres s'est réunis et
bien sûr le 49-3 était abordé alors moi
je vous demande et j'aimerais avoir une
réponse dès le début de nos débats
est-ce que les débats qui vont s'exercer
ici dans cette Assemblée nationale
devant la représentation la
représentation nationale pardon va
servir à quelque chose ou allez vous
couper court quand quoi comment avec un
49 ans nous ne pouvons pas du tout
adhérer au projet où vous nous emmener
messieurs les ministres parce que vous
remettez à plus tard vous remettez au
calendrier l'ensemble des pistes
d'économie possible il n'y a aucun début
aucune recherche de piste d'économie
dans le budget que vous nous présentez
et l'élément essentiel vous le savez
nous le savons tous il faut agir sur les
dépenses publiques pour retrouver des
marges de manœuvre pour pouvoir investir
pour le futur pour les générations à
venir ces textes la loi de programmation
comme l'article éliminaire cadre les
dépenses explique les soldes font des
différences entre ce qui est structurel
et ce qui ne l'est pas il pose le
paysage des lois de finances sans
s'imposer à elle chacun garde évidemment
ou chacun assemblée des hard chaque
séance garde une liberté de vote totale
refuser des cadrages refuser les mises
en perspective ne pas voter des lois de
programmation c'est quand même d'une
certaine manière refus l'idée de la
maîtrise des finances publiques parce
qu'en général on est pour la maîtrise
des finances publiques en général mais
elle rend particuliers c'est beaucoup
plus dur beaucoup plus difficile il y a
pas un groupe ici mais par un seul qui
accepte en général une baisse de
dépenses donc il faut juste essayer à un
moment donné d'être cohérent avec
soi-même un mot de cet article linéaire
il est évidemment dans la droite suite
de la loi de programmation dont nous
avons débattu jusqu'à tard hier soir et
dans le cadre de laquelle nous avons
proposé une autre trajectoire nous
n'avons pas cédé à la facilité de ne pas
faire des contre-propositions à celles
que nous que nous contestions
dividendes nous ne partageons pas ni vos
perspectives niveau prévisions ni les
choix politiques qui sont les vôtres et
d'évidence nous ne voterons pas cet
article linéaire mais je voudrais
au-delà de cela poser au ministre la
question du temps qui nous est imparti
pour débattre des amendements que nous
avons déposés dont je ferai remarquer
qu'ils sont sur nos bancs tout à fait
raisonnable du point de vue de leur
nombre compte tenu de l'importance du
texte que nous examinons et que
évidemment il ne serait pas être il ne
serait pas raisonnable que de plaider de
votre côté une quelques obstructions que
ce soit évidemment notre souhait mais
nous voyons déjà l'épée de Damoclès
poindre c'est de pouvoir débattre et
faire vivre cette assemblée nous ne fait
espérons jamais de vous convaincre du
bien fondé de nos propositions donc la
question qui est la mienne c'est bien
celle-là
combien de temps laissez-vous au débat
parlementaire et l'irrémédiable est-il
certain nous prendrons le temps
nécessaire pour avoir le meilleur budget
possible pour la France après viendra un
moment où il faudra bien qu'il y ait un
budget pour la France et le gouvernement
naturellement prendra ses
responsabilités parce que nous n'allons
pas laisser nos compatriotes sans budget
pour 2023 sans capacité à payer les
fonctionnaires à payer les allocations
sociales à payer un certain nombre de
dépenses militaires pour les policiers
pour les gendarmes pour nos services
publics donc nous prendrons nos
responsabilités mais nous ne les
prendrons qu'au terme d'un débat
approfondie où chacun pourra exprimer
ses vues sur ce qui est bon pour le P et
parce que nous sommes dans des
conditions économiques nouvelles
marquées par le retour de l'inflation je
pense qu'il serait déraisonnable d'aller
trop vite dans la réduction à la dépense
publique d'aller trop vite dans le
rétablissement des finances publiques
nous avons déjà fait l'erreur en 2010 en
2012 ne la refaisons pas en 2022
enfin un dernier point sur l'hypothèse
de croissance
vous me dites que tous les instituts
nous mettent extrêmement loin des
prévisions du gouvernement le FMI qui
est un institut crédible il me semble
pour reprendre les termes ont été
employés bien indiqué que l'un des pays
de la zone euro qui sont sortis le mieux
en 2023 serait probablement la France
nous en venons donc au vote de l'article
liminaire
par scrutin public
je vous remercie de regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
[Musique]
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 368 exprimé
367 majorité 184 pour 175 contre 192
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
l'article liminaire est rejeté et ce ne
sera pas la seule déconvenue pour le
gouvernement cette fois l'offensive
vient du MoDem il ne veut pas taxer les
super profits mais les super dividendes
l'initiative est saluée par les
oppositions qui se réjouissent de voir
une majorité divisée
il s'agit d'un amendement qui concerne
les super profits et surtout les super
dividendes
on a beaucoup parlé de super profit il y
a une mission flash qui a été menée par
la commission des finances nous on pense
que c'est difficilement applicable en
l'état contenu de la fiscalité
internationale des établissements
stables mais se pose la question des
super dividendes qui sont distribuées et
c'est un amendement qui est encadré qui
concerne les entreprises qui réalisent
plus de 750 millions de chiffre
d'affaires qui réalisent des super
profits mais qui décident de distribuer
des super dividendes et l'idée c'est de
prévoir une flaque tax à 35% pour les
super dividendes qui seraient distribués
et qui correspondrait à 20% de la
moyenne des cinq dernières années le
distribution dividendes donc il faudrait
un Coran dans la catégorie des super
profits et de que l'on puisse avoir une
notion de de super dividende distribué
qui est relativement encadré par la
réglementation je rappelle d'ailleurs
que pour les petits épargnants qui
recevraient des dividendes ils ont
toujours la possibilité d'opter un impôt
sur le revenu sans pas obligés d'être
inflack taxe donc on pourrait considérer
que cette taxe à 35% de majorée aurait
un petit caractère confiscatoire pour
des revenus moyens je rappelle qu'il est
toujours possible d'opter un impôt sur
le revenu au titre des revenus de
distribution de dividendes ça concerne
également le rachat d'actions des
sociétés puisque là aussi on a un
problème avec le rachat d'action dans ce
type de je dirais de qui réalise de
super profits mais comme vous le savez
il y aurait là aussi des difficultés à
déterminer ce que sont des super
dividendes vous savez qu'il y a pour les
dividendes comme pour les résultats une
certaine volatilité d'une année sur
l'autre en fonction des résultats de
l'entreprise et une entreprise qui
n'aurait pas distribué par exemple de
dividendes pendant longtemps et qui le
ferait l'année où vous faites cette
supertax elle serait elle serait
pénalisée dans tous les cas celui qui le
reçoit serait pénalisé donc je crois
qu'il y a déjà une
difficulté méthodologique ensuite vous
rappeler vous le savez mieux que
quiconque il a déjà les dividendes sont
imposées n'ont plus laisser croire que
les 10 ans ne sont pas abonnés ils sont
imposés une première fois évidemment au
niveau des résultats de l'entreprise
donc ils sont imposés à 25% ils sont
imposés par celui qui les reçoit à
hauteur de la flat tax 30%. donc il y a
déjà une une imposition assez lourde sur
les dividendes reçues
ce qui les touches donc je ne crois pas
qu'il faille aujourd'hui prendre le
risque déstabiliser une fois de plus
vous savez qu'on est très attentif à la
stabilité de la fiscalité dans le temps
pour créer un climat de confiance pour
les entreprises pour les actionnaires
pour les investisseurs voilà c'est
plutôt une proposition de demande de
retrait et me paraît pas opportun de le
faire aujourd'hui vous le savez sur la
question des bénéfices exceptionnels des
profits exceptionnels en temps de crise
notamment dans les secteurs de l'énergie
nous avons travaillé un dispositif
européen qui a été adopté au niveau
européen et que nous allons je l'espère
transcrire dans le droit français avec
les amendements qui seront discutés en
la matière je crois que c'est après
l'article 4 on prend les sujets les uns
après les autres et donc je pense que
l'essentiel dans ce texte c'est
d'appliquer le dispositif qui a été
imaginé au niveau européen et qui va
être adopté par la majorité des pays de
l'Union européenne nous donc soutenir
l'amendement de notre collègue du
président Mattei pardon et et nous
réjouir et nous réjouir que car
finalement avec cet amendement en tout
le monde reconnaît enfin qu'il y a des
supers profits c'est un amendement très
raisonnable très constructif qui à mon
avis peut rassembler tout le monde pour
avancer sur un sujet qui fera du bien la
démocratie et à la justice fiscale vous
avez le président d'un groupe
parlementaire de votre regroupement qui
propose un amendement qui a un
amendement de compromis et même sur ce
sujet vous êtes pas capable de donner un
avis favorable franchement et après vous
allez nous dire vous écoutez pas vous
voulez pas travailler avec nous vous
nous dites vous allez déstabiliser le
versement des dividendes mais vous
inquiétez pas monsieur le ministre cette
année au deuxième trimestre de l'année
2022 le versement des dividendes en
France a atteint un record historique
une augmentation de plus de 33% on n'a
jamais vu ça c'est un record alors à
minima faire en sorte qu'il participe un
petit peu la solidarité nationale je
crois que c'est une mesure de bon sens
et qui devrait rassembler extrêmement
largement sur ses bandes donc oui nous
votre hausse dispositif et on espère
qu'on sera nombreux à le faire merci et
avec le groupe horizon nous espérons
pouvoir vous proposer effectivement un
outil qui accompagnera davantage le
partage de la valeur et la valorisation
de l'actionnariat salarié c'est pour ça
qu'à ce stade le groupe horizon
s'abstiendra sur cette amendement
finalement là ce que vous essayez de
faire c'est de taxer les dividendes qui
seraient perçus et Manon d'une
entreprise
qui a un chiffre d'affaires supérieur à
750 millions d'euros c'est à dire qu'on
pourrait se trouver dans une situation
ou une personne perçoit de très très
gros dividendes de très très gros
dividendes des montants très importants
et maintenant d'une entreprise dont le
chiffre d'affaires serait inférieur à
750 millions et cette personne serait
taxée à 30%. en revanche en revanche une
personne qui bénéficierait de
[Musique]
les seuls qui n'ont pas besoin de
quémander pour se gaver ce sont les
profiteurs de guerre
les seuls à qui on dit qu'il faut se
tourner vers Bruxelles pour demander
l'autorisation des taxer c'est ceux qui
font du pognon dormant et donc on va
voter l'amendement de notre collègue
parce qu'il prend le pognon là où il
faut le prendre pour le donner là où on
a besoin on peut évidemment avoir tous
les débats on est là pour ça on peut
chercher toutes les solutions toutes les
idées on est là pour ça aussi je
rappelle simplement deux choses il y a
un mécanisme qui a été trouvé au niveau
européen qui aujourd'hui décliné dans
les différents États membres il peut y
avoir des discussions des débats sur
d'autres sujets on peut les avoir est-ce
que il faut que ça se fasse comme ça
dans le cadre d'un amendement ici ou
est-ce qu'on peut se poser pour en
parler c'est la première chose je pose
une question la deuxième chose moi je
dis simplement je dis simplement que
depuis trois ans la France est redevenue
le pays le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers en Europe tous
les baromètres indépendants le disent je
dis qu'on a le taux de chômage le plus
bas depuis 15 ans je dis que pour la
première fois depuis 15 ans on a des
emplois industriels qui se recrée dans
notre pays qu'on a l'activité qui
redémarre que tout ça on le doit à une
politique qui est cohérente et j'arrête
simplement sur l'effet signal de
dispositif qui viendrait brouiller
brouiller cette politique qui a été mise
en place depuis 5 ans et qui porte ses
fruits c'est tout après chacun prend sa
responsabilités résultat du scrutin
votant 335 exprimés 315 majorité 158
pour 227 contre 88
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
autre disposition votée contre la vie du
gouvernement le rétablissement de
l'exitax Emmanuel Macron avait allégé
cette impôts qui visait les Français qui
s'installaient à l'étranger
l'amendement vient des républicains
il s'agit de revenir sur le dispositif
tel qu'il a évolué dans le cas de la loi
de finance 2019 sur l'exit tax l'exit
tax avait été instauré à la demande et
sous la décision et l'influence de
Nicolas Sarkozy alors président de la
République l'idée c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on évite une forme d'évasion
fiscale qui consiste lorsqu'on est chef
d'entreprise ou qu'on a des actions
importantes à quitter le pays à changer
son domicile fiscal pour éviter de payer
la plus-value lors de la session ensuite
de ses actions et donc il avait été
instauré cette exit taxe qui a pour
objectif sans remettre en cause la
propriété évidemment de l'entrepreneur
en question ou de l'actionnaire en
question de faire en sorte qu'on n'est
pas d'évasion fiscale le qui avait été
fixé était le maintien pendant 15 ans
était le maintien pendant 15 ans dans la
propriété de l'actionnaire de ses
actions au terme de ces 15 années dans
le dispositif Sarkozy il y avait un
remboursement ou en tout cas s'il y
avait eu comment dire un décalage dans
le paiement une autorisation du fisc à
ce moment-là le fait que le contribuable
se retrouver effectivement non imposable
ce délai a été rapporté à deux ans en
2019 et il est évident que deux ans ça
ne ça ne tient pas c'est extrêmement
facile c'est le dispositif n'est plus
effectif et donc nous proposons par cet
amendement simplement dans un souci de
régulation être libéral c'est aussi
savoir réguler de revenir au délai de 15
ans qui avait été mis en place à
l'époque de Nicolas Sarkozy
vous souhaitez rétablir les petites
taxes tel qu'il existait avant 2018
effectivement le débat parlementaire qui
avait lieu à cette époque avait montré à
la fois son effet plutôt délétère sur
l'image de la France et sur les
investissements qui pouvaient avoir lieu
en France les débat parlementaire avait
aussi montré à cette époque le roman
très faible de cette taxe et donc nous
avions recentré cette exact pour éviter
les abus donc nous partageons l'objectif
il y a un délai de deux ans mais aussi
un délai de 5 ans donc notre objectif
c'est vraiment de lutter contre les abus
mais faire en sorte que notre pays reste
attractif pour les investisseurs et
qu'ils aient envie de venir investir en
France sans risquer quand il partent une
une fiscalisation trop importante donc
la vie défavorable l'exit tax il n'a de
valeur puisque enfin je suis un peu
étonné que le rapporteur général disent
que c'est pour susciter la tractivité de
d'autres places financières puisqu'en
réalité les zitacles il est il est très
ciblé il cible ceux de nos concitoyens
qui partent à l'étranger pour en réalité
faire de l'évasion fiscale sur une mais
oui c'est bien évidemment c'est pour ça
que Nicolas Sarkozy avait ciblé pour
c'est clair il y a des concitoyens qui
font ça moi je crois que notre politique
fiscale les choix que nous faisons que
nous avons fait ces dernières années
elle doit s'apprécier comme un tout elle
a un objectif c'est de renforcer
l'attractivité de notre pays c'est pour
ça que nous avons fait la baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés c'est pour ça
que nous avons fait la baisse des impôts
de production c'est pour ça que nous
avons fait la réforme de l'exit tax
aussi si cette politique n'avait pas
obtenu des résultats j'entends je
pourrais entendre un certain nombre de
critiques et de débats or elle a des
résultats depuis trois ans notre pays
est à nouveau le plus attractif en
Europe pour les investissements
étrangers le nombre de concitoyens qui
quittent notre pays pour des raisons
fiscales a considérablement baissé
l'attractivité de notre pays c'est
renforcer donc on voit bien qu'il y a un
impact positif assez réformes qui ont
été portées rappelons effectivement le
contexte de l'adoption de l'exit taxe
par la majorité
UMP à l'époque en 2008 et qui devait
effectivement rapporter 800 millions
d'euros c'est l'évaluation qui a été
faite par le Conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires et il est vrai qu'on l'a
remarqué qu'elle rapportait beaucoup
moins cette taxe moins de 100 millions
d'euros chaque année et qu'a fait
finalement cette réforme de 2019 et bien
elle a encore réduit le rendement de cet
axe rappelons le principe c'est une
taxation des plus-values latente sur les
actions détenues par quelqu'un qui part
de France et la révision de 2019 a fait
baisser le délai de détention des
actions de 15 ans à 2 ans et donc pour
cette raison l'exit taxes aujourd'hui ne
frappe quasiment plus personne et un
rendement très très faible être libéral
c'est savoir réguler et vous avez porté
ensuite le propos sur la fraude fiscale
et l'optimisation fiscale mais là ça
n'est pas le sujet je pense que vous
vous trompez de sujet le sujet c'est la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale parce que
je vais vous donner un exemple tout
simple quelqu'un qui envisage de céder
ces actions de vendre son entreprise
dans quelques années parce que tout ça
se prépare de manière importante sur des
des actes de cette nature décide au 31
décembre 2022 de quitter le pays va
payer effectivement l'impôt sur les
plus-values latentes vendra à son
entreprise dans trois ans et sera se
trouvera est exonéré sur une grande
partie de sa plus-value voilà et ça
c'est de l'évasion fiscale et nous
devons tous ensemble lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale et vous le savez je me
rejoins c'est quand même pas anodin de
se retrouver sur les mêmes propos que
que le président de la commission des
finances Éric Coquerel
c'est très important vous nous devons
avoir du bon sens parce que nos
concitoyens ne comprennent pas ça et
vous le savez nous sommes libéral mais
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale nous
devons tous nous retrouver
on ne peut pas dire à la fois que la
France est à l'euro près dire que nous
avons besoin de ressources pour financer
nos services publics et ne pas imposer
les plus-values de ceux qui s'installent
à l'étranger parfois pour échapper à
l'impôt et à la solidarité nationale
monsieur dame chers
ne sont pas des pigeons les Français de
l'étranger ne sont pas des évadés
fiscaux
aurions-nous aurions-nous 25 licornes en
France si nous continuions à pénaliser
les entrepreneurs français pour leur
succès
c'est amendement c'est un manquement qui
sort le spectre de François Hollande de
son placard
propose de pénaliser à l'avance ceux qui
oseraient réussir dans 10 ans dans 15
ans
est-ce que vous savez seulement pourquoi
les entrepreneurs français qui décident
de quitter la France quittent le pays
est-ce que vous le savez au-delà de
l'épouvantail de Bernard Arnault que
vous que vous agitez régulièrement pour
pour exciter les foules il suffit de
regarder la liste des pays destinations
de nos entrepreneurs vous n'y trouverez
ni en or ni le Panama ni Monaco
nioriestenstein vous y trouverez en
numéro 1 les États-Unis en numéro 2
l'Espagne 8% en numéro 3 l'Allemagne
Royaume-Uni Italie parlons de l'Espagne
parlons de l'Espagne deuxième
destination des entrepreneurs français
qui s'expatrient ils payeront 27% de
plus-value d'imposition sur les
plus-values à la vente de leur
entreprise en Espagne ils seront soumis
à Barcelone un taux d'imposition sur le
patrimoine un ISF de trois et demi pour
cent pour pour les capitales supérieur à
10 millions à comparer à feu l'ISF qui
imposait 1,5%
, ce ne sont pas des événements fiscaux
ce sont des gens qui choisissent de
quitter la France pour participer à
l'expansion internationale de leur
société pour aller s'installer à
Barcelone à Lisbonne des endroits où il
trouve un marché de l'emploi qui leur
offre des employés qui ont la capacité
la capacité de s'exprimer dans des
langues que vous ne parlerez jamais
merci merci de conclure chers collègues
merci de conclure qui offre une qualité
de la vie que vous ne pourrez jamais
imposer
ne laissez pas vos fantasmes empêcher
ces Français de vivre la vie qu'il
choisisse et de participer au
rayonnement de la France à l'étranger ne
votez pas pour cet amendement et que
chacun contribue un peu à mesure de ses
moyens et donc il faut oui il faut voter
cet amendement sur l'exit tax un
amendement qui est absolument
remarquable et aujourd'hui soutenu par
tous les membres de la commission des
finances sauf la majorité minoritaire je
vous remercie évidemment
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut faire le bilan tout de
même du ruissellement parce que ça a été
la philosophie principale de votre
politique économique ça n'a pas
fonctionné et ça n'est pas le
rassemblement national qui le dit c'est
France stratégie et France stratégie
n'est pas une officine qui est dirigée
par le rassemblement national ils ont
fait un rapport en 2021 pour analyser et
étudier les conséquences de votre
politique flat taxe ISF réforme
précisément de l'exigtax ça n'a pas
fonctionné il n'y a pas eu de
ruissellement la politique est fait de
mots
c'est bien normal mais moi je considère
avec les élus du groupe lyaute que
au-delà de ce qu'on dit nous serons
jugés sur que ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui voter favorablement cet
amendement c'est nous permettre d'être
en cohérence avec ce que vivent les
Français nous avons besoin
nous avons besoin d'envoyer des signaux
ceux qui consiste à dire que oui ne
comprenons la situation et que oui ceux
qui sont les plus aisés et qui par leur
comportement interroge sur leur capacité
à faire vivre la solidarité nationale
doivent être en situation d'être
encadrées évidemment et naturellement
nous voterons cet amendement au regard
du rendement de cette impôt en aucune
manière certains pots ne va régler les
problèmes d'injustice sociale donc
ce sujet là ne répond pas absolument pas
à ce que vous demandez il y a un
deuxième point c'est que effectivement
cet amendement par du principe que un
chef d'entreprise qui voyage qui
déménagent est un fraudeur c'est quand
même incroyable d'entendre dans
certaines interventions des élus
politiques qui ont l'air de regretter
que la situation s'améliore est-ce que
ça va bien pour tout le monde la réponse
est non évidemment mais enfin je veux
dire à un moment à un moment quand vous
avez des choses qui s'améliorent
reconnaissez-le soutenez-le c'est bon
pour le pays c'est pas uniquement bon
pour la majorité résultat du scrutin
votant 293 exprimé 288 majorité 145 pour
155 contre 1303 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
après plusieurs revers le gouvernement
prend la décision d'arrêter l'examen du
texte la première ministre Elisabeth
borne arrive à l'Assemblée nationale et
avec elle le recours à l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution
[Applaudissements]
les oppositions sont toutes réaffirmer
leur volonté de rejeter le texte
en responsabilité nous devons donner un
budget à notre pays
les Français attendent de nous de la
cohérence de l'action et des résultats
aussi
aussi sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
mais ce 49-3 ne marque pas la fin des
débats budgétaires en effet le budget
est composé d'une partie recette celle
sur laquelle la première ministre vient
d'engager la responsabilité de son
gouvernement mais également d'une partie
dépense sans surprise le scénario se
répète avec un gouvernement mis en
minorité par les oppositions notamment
sur le budget de la transition
écologique
le gouvernement lui-même a constaté
l'échec de ma prime rénov sur les
rénovations globales seulement 2500
logements qui ont changé de performance
énergétique le rapport spécial lui-même
montre que seulement 5% des rénovations
sont des réseauxnations globales et je
rappelle que le reste à charge pour les
ménages très modestes et de 37% pour des
rénovations qui sont de l'ordre de 38000
euros donc on voit bien c'est tout à
fait impossible pour un ménage modeste
de faire une rénovation globale et
derrière cet enjeu il y a des gens il y
a des ménages 4,8 millions de ménages
qui vivent dans des passoires thermiques
et qui vont voir qui voit déjà
d'ailleurs leur facture énergétique
flambée et qui vont passer un hiver très
froid à cause de cette politique qui ne
prend pas en charge la rénovation
globale donc vous nous avez demandé des
propositions les voilà elles sont
assises sur le rapport Sichel et sur
iforcy le chiffrage il est connu de tous
c'est un rapport que vous avez commandé
vous-même il est très clair il faut 9,3
milliards d'euros par an pour sur 10 ans
pour traiter l'ensemble des passoires
thermiques en France et c'est grâce à
ces 9,3 milliards d'euros et uniquement
en atteignant ce niveau là que l'on
pourra vraiment traiter ce sujet il faut
aller vers un reste à charge 0 pour les
ménages très modestes et 5% pour les
manages modestes nous vous soumettons
même un barème au sein de cet amendement
donc je vous invite vraiment à en
prendre connaissance et à suivre les
recommandations du rapport que vous avez
commandé le rapport si cher augmenter
les moyens pour la rénovation thermique
la réponse est aussi oui et d'ailleurs
le gouvernement propose une augmentation
de 450 millions d'euros cette année ce
qui n'augmentation de 25% qui fait que
non seulement les crédits du plan de
relance sont sanctuarisés mais qu'ils
sont considérablement amplifiés alors
est-ce que augmenter de 7 milliards
d'euros puisque c'est la proposition
vous faites dès l'an prochain dès 2023
les crédits à louer à la rénovation des
logements permettrait de résoudre cette
question ben là je vais la réponse est
non et c'est là où nos différents
pourquoi parce que qu'est-ce qui empêche
désormais de pouvoir faire de la
rénovation mais c'est pas que les
questions budgétaires c'est vous avez un
problème d'accompagnement des ménages
vous avez un problème de structuration
de la filière de l'offre de nos artisans
pour qu'ils soient en capacité
d'effectuer des rénovations globales
vous avez une un problème de suivi de
qualité des travaux par des choses sur
lesquels il faut qu'on travaille vous
avez un problème de déclenchement des
travaux dans un salon de copropriété où
les freins réglementaires de procédures
sont très importants et donc pour toutes
ces raisons et pas seulement pour des
raisons comptables je crois que
l'amendement que vous proposez ne répond
pas à l'objectif que vous poursuivez
avis donc défavorable
il faut un peu de modestie voilà vous ne
pouvez pas sans cesse parce qu'on l'a
remarqué dans d'autres réponses être
l'arbitre des élégances techniques
espace que Monsieur Beaune sorte
d'accord avec vous et que quelqu'un vous
dit que vous avez tous les deux à ce que
l'on dit en sachant peut-être que l'un
de l'autre on sait pas qui est le plus
mauvais peut-être que vous rassurez
comme ça mais c'est pas le cas mais vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas l'arbitre des
compétences du groupe RN ou des
différents groupes de la nups voilà
quand la Cour des comptes quand la Cour
des comptes adresse un tel bilan il y a
un moment vu l'argent qui a été mis sur
la table il faut un peu de modestie
voilà donc la vraie question qui se pose
ensuite par rapport même si on
soutiendra madame ça c'est qu'on voit
bien qu'en fait quel que soit les
montants du budget l'instrument
budgétaire n'est sans doute pas le bon
pour financer la rénovation thermique et
la rénovation des des logements je pense
que le Parlement devrait s'interroger
sur la création d'un nouveau instrument
financier qui permet de dégager en fait
les dizaines de milliards parce qu'on
sait tous que c'est ça l'enjeu des
montants il faut dégager des dizaines de
milliards d'euros sur un demi-siècle qui
permettent la rénovation des logements
donc il faudrait que le Parlement
réfléchissent sur un nouvel instrument
financier qui permet en fait de financer
cette transition avec des grands
équilibres parce qu'on ne pourra jamais
adosser au budget les montants
nécessaires à la rénovation et chaque
année on constatera que l'argent n'est
pas suffisant parce qu'en fait on se
trouve l'instrument financier ma prime
rénove effectivement vous le dites la
ministre c'est 2,5 milliards d'euros
mais c'est très loin des ambitions cela
a été rappelé par notre collègue ça
c'est la Cour des comptes qui le dit ce
sont 2500 passoires qui ont perdu cette
cette nature et alors qu'il y avait un
objectif de 80000 ou 90 000 et les
députés les républicains nous avons
porté en première partie un amendement
proposant un crédit d'impôt pour
justement soutenir apporter une aide aux
propriétaires habitants ou aux
propriétaires bailleurs en laissant
d'ailleurs le soin au gouvernement de
fixer les taux le plafond et je dirais
amendement qui avait été adopté en
commission des finances en première
partie et en séance et nous pouvons
regretter que le gouvernement ne l'est
pas repris dans son texte article 49-3
nous avons
une situation qui va arriver devant nous
qui va être catastrophique en termes de
logement compte tenu notamment de
l'interdiction des de certains logements
qui ne pourront plus être soumis à la
location dès le 1er janvier 2023 donc si
nous n'apportons pas une aide un soutien
à tous ces propriétaires il y aura une
vraie crise du logement en France et il
est de notre devoir d'anticiper
d'apporter un soutien à une aide un
soutien pour qu'effectivement nous
avantion encore beaucoup plus vite sur
la rénovation thermique des logements
mes chers collègues d'abord pour pour
souligner si c'était encore nécessaire
qu'il s'agit d'un amendement à 7
milliards d'euros un amendement à 7
milliards d'euros dans le contexte que
nous connaissons et sur lequel s'il vous
plaît sur lequel je me permets
d'insister
on peut effectivement tout mélanger
on peut effectivement tout mélanger ou
alors on peut décider d'avoir une
discussion sereine sur le sujet on a eu
une discussion sereine continuons
après on va voter c'est important
allez-y juste premièrement quand on
parle d'argent et vous mentionnez à très
juste titre de nombreux rapports qui ont
fait état des besoins de financement on
ne parle pas que de ma prime rénov on
parle aussi des plus de 2 milliards
d'euros de taux de TVA réduit qui
permettent de rénover énergétiquement
les logements on permet des plus de 3
milliards d'euros qui grâce aux
certificat d'économie d'énergie
permettent de financer indirectement la
rénovation énergétique on parle de ma
prime rénov sérénité on parle de ma
prime rénov copropriété donc si on parle
d'argent public direct ou indirectement
investi il faut faire la somme générale
et la deuxième raison qui est la plus
importante on l'a abordé en commission
et je crois qu'il émergeait un consensus
sur ce sujet c'est que c'est d'abord une
un sujet d'accompagnement nous avons
besoin d'identifier davantage les
passoires énergétiques nous avons besoin
de mieux comprendre comment accompagner
les ménages et pourquoi
et pourquoi aujourd'hui les ménages les
plus modestes alors que de nombreux
outils existent ne font pas encore assez
de rénovation performante et donc à ce
titre je salue l'engagement du
gouvernement à partir du 1er janvier de
mettre en place un accompagnement
beaucoup plus personnalisé beaucoup plus
efficace pas seulement pour ma prime
réunion sérénité mais aussi pour ma
prime rénove et donc je vous incite à la
raison et à la parcimonie budgétaire sur
ce sujet qui est pour le 1400
qui est contre il est adopté
[Applaudissements]
la chorégraphie est désormais connue la
première ministre Elisabeth borne monte
à la tribune et annonce recourir à
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
ma conviction celle du gouvernement et
celle de la majorité c'est que l'on ne
doit pas opposer transition écologique
et aide à nos compatriotes les plus
modestes c'est qu'on ne doit pas opposer
le climat et le pouvoir d'achat
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvons les concilier et c'est ce
que propose ce texte puisque nous
investissons davantage pour la
transition écologique et que dans le
même temps nous protégeons les Français
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
de leur côté les amendements votés
explosent de plein fouet nos
compatriotes à l'inflation
aussi puisque les conditions d'un
dialogue constructif ne sont plus réunis
puisque des mesures protectrices et
attendues ont été balayés dans les
débats puisque le projet de loi est
profondément dénaturé nous devons réagir
aussi aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la deuxième partie et
l'ensemble du projet de loi de finance
pour 2023
au total sur le budget la première
ministre aura recours à 5 reprises à
l'article 49-3 5 fois également pour le
budget de la Sécurité sociale soit 10
fois au total pour le marathon
budgétaire voilà pour ce résumé de la
bataille du budget à très vite sur LCP
[Musique]